George we're gonna have to wrap this up
pretty soon is there anything that
you've always wanted to ask me because
George I will yes yes there is something
I want to ask you how the [ __ ] do you
write so many books so fast I think oh
I've had a really good six months I've
written three chapters and you've got
three books in that time here's the
thing okay there are there are books in
there are books the way that that the
way that I work I try to get out there
and I try to get six pages a day so with
a book like end of watch and I work when
I'm working I work every day three four
hours and I try to get those six pages
and I try to get them fairly clean so if
the manuscript is let's say three
hundred and sixty pages long that's
basically two months work it's
concentrated but it's a fairly but
that's assuming that it goes well and
you do hit six pages a day I usually do
you don't ever have a day where you sit
down there and it's like constipation
and you write a sentence and you hate
the sentence and okay you check your
email and you wonder if you had any
Talent after all and maybe you should
have been a plumber
don't yes tastes like that no I mean
this real life you know I can be working
away and something comes up and you have
to basically get up and you have to go
to see the doctor or you have to take
somebody care package or you have to go
to the post office because whatever but
mostly I try to get the six pages in
although entropy tries to intervene you
know I I did an event at Radio City
Music Hall for charity with John Irving
and Joe rolling and this was that JK
Rowling
and this was at the time that she was
finishing the seventh Harry Potter books
and I know that I've been very fortunate
as a writer and you've been terrific ly
fortunate as a writer you worked for a
long time wrote a lot of good books won
a lot of awards and then out of nowhere
all of a sudden this crazy thing happens
where all these books are suddenly New
York Times bestsellers and God knows is
deserved but it's a sort of sudden thing
and here's the other thing okay
people yelling at you and say we want
the next book we want the next book
they're like babies we want the next
book right away I mean it's it's a great
thing to want that but the the pressure
that you feel or I feel compared to that
final Harry Potter book you know
everybody everybody wanted that and she
came to New York and she was nearly
finished with it and she'd agreed to do
this event and Joe was trying to do
three things at once she was going to do
a vacation with her kids she was going
to finish the last five or six chapters
of the seventh Harry Potter book and she
was going to do this event and she
showed up to do the soundcheck at Radio
City Music Hall and she was just like
any housewife or mother or anyone who
was on vacation she had a shell top on
and white clam digger pants and and
loafers or sandals or something and her
hair tied back in horse tails and we
were trying to talk about what we were
going to do and everything and the
scholastic Press published is pulling
her aside and talking to her and Joe is
very polite but when she came back and
talked to me she was really really angry
and what she said was they don't
understand what we do do they and I said
how can they understand when we don't
understand all too true